so it is now pretty well established and
pretty well agreed upon that cutting
emissions is in theory the right thing
to do what's a lot less clear is not
just how we do it but crucially who
should be doing what and importantly as
well how exactly are we going to pay for
it so first of all let's just take a
look at where we're at post this big uh
economic recession we've had this huge
shock to the economy has it left us with
emissions that are higher or lower than
what they were before the pandemic well
the answer is um so so as you can see
there the pink line is the uk average so
the average emissions were ever so
slightly below what they were that 100
line uh in 2019 and we've plotted on a
couple of key sectors there and as you
can see the general story is that yes
there were a bit of fluctuations
particularly there in the spring when we
came out of lockdown the economy all
reopening but things were sort of
roughly what they were the key outlier
and exception as you can see in the
orange there aviation emissions in that
sector significantly down but of course
we all know that wasn't necessarily by
design but because of the restrictions
that that sector was laboring under now
a lot of people said that as we were
pumping billions into the economies
different countries doing that to
recover from the pandemic this would
have been a really good excuse a really
good opportunity to invest in more green
and did countries do that did they use
this opportunity
to make their recovery spending green
spending so essentially what we've done
along the bottom line here is the
percentage of covered recovery spending
in different countries that was green
spending up on this axis here
essentially at the proportion of a
country's gdp that the spending was and
as you can see there are a couple of
countries belgium canada who really did
prioritize uh green spending as part of
their recoveries but the larger
economies particularly those as well who
were very hard hit by the pandemic
not so much and essentially i think what
this is showing us is that when chips
were down when times were hard it is
difficult to prioritize this type of
spending and perhaps that's not hugely
surprising because we know this stuff is
expensive we know it is really really
difficult and i want to just show you
this just to give a bit of an insight
about just how difficult and just how
expensive it might be this is the uk's
uh sort of domestic carbon emissions
going back to 1990 as you can see
they're going down we know that the
targets are hitting at zero by 2050. but
just look at this when we add in the
emissions that comes just from the
import
of goods so that part of domestic trade
hugely higher uh probably hugely harder
to bring down and we have to ask
ourselves after a summer of supply chain
problems the importance that we're
placing on global global trade right now
are we going to have the stomach to
really radically overhaul that system
and how we're going to do it it's going
to be very very difficult uh indeed so
who is doing what well what this is
showing you is the percentage of
companies cities states and regions and
countries who have actually made net
zero promises so far so 61 of countries
have made some sort of net zero promise
but look companies only 21 of the 2000
largest companies in the in the world
have made a net zero pledge at all
however when you look at the quality of
the net zero pledges that have been made
by countries and companies slightly
different story this big chunk in the
yellow here from the countries
essentially shows us that of those net
zero promises that have been made a lot
of them are just at that stage of
proposal or discussion however companies
when they have made a zero promise much
more likely to be in the purple there uh
in policy document and strategy
essentially a sense that if a net zero
promise is made by a company it's being
taken a little bit more seriously worth
just pointing out that orange bit there
companies have actually achieved more of
their net zero promises as well but
still at pretty low levels so huge
problems huge challenges not just in
terms of what to do but how to
prioritize it and very crucially as i
said as well who's going to pay for it
sam thank you